yes sir Gotham to Gotham hello everyone
my name is Tamara chambers I'm Jake
Jarvie and this is Tamara just saw and I
was there too I'm gonna say right out of
the gate I had problems with this film
but I also loved it before seeing the
film we were both like oh I'm I'm
hopeful yeah I should mark I have
optimism question mark kept eclis
hopeful yeah because of Joss Whedon's
involvement for me
I know Zack Snyder was pretty well into
this when the unfortunate awful awful
stuff happened to his family aside from
everything that happened I will say that
I am
I love Joss Whedon hi I feel like this
started over as soon as Joss showed up
they were like what do you need to do he
did a rewrite yeah he kept maybe two
dialogue scenes and a couple of action
shots because so so little of this
looked like a Zack Snyder movie but a
few did and so it felt a tiny bit to me
that it was kind of like a little cut
and paste like a tiny sure-sure a couple
scenes and data and we're like that was
abrupt that was abrupt yeah it was wait
it's like okay like who am i but like
first of all I needs to be said anytime
henry cavill was on screen hey i could
not get past it the fact that from his
nose to his gums haha upper gums were
CGI I was amazed how much it threw me
off like just if just this portion of a
human's face is CG I loved the opening I
thought it was really a nice
light-hearted whole movie felt
light-hearted more than any other DC
film has ever felt this is truth I
should mention as well that I super
enjoyed this movie as well
I did not expect ooh yeah I had a great
time its people its people yeah it's not
the super it's the man yeah not the God
it's the human yeah it's a
two people who are having conversations
in a very entertaining way and every
time action would arrive I would just be
like I wish Barry Allen was talking
again
I just wanted justice for the flash and
I didn't think that Barry Allen was
gonna get great screen time he was by
far the like comedic relief of this film
was amazing he's so good and I was so
relieved because I just didn't think he
was gonna get that also I think that
many people maybe this is just me
putting this on myself but I think a lot
of people are gonna leave this and want
to compare it to like Thor that just
came out Ragnarok and like guardians the
galaxy and the Marvel Universe is what
they're doing with Kombi it's the bane
of existence these exist and this can be
different and that's cool it is
different
I thought the comedy in this worked for
what this is trying to be this Justice
League felt very much to me like the
Hangout scenes of the Avengers this is
everybody trying to pick up Thor's
hammer yeah and to understand it all
looks kind of green screened because I
believe they started over Zack Snyder's
name is on this thing yeah speaking of
names being on this thing I gotta talk
about Danny Elfman who scored this
during several sections of this movie
heroic Batman moments of which there are
few the Batman 89 theme from Tim
Burton's Batman would weave in Danny
Elfman wrote it it reappears here very
subtly and it made my heart soar
I'm glad Batman was not a leading part
of this group no well he well he was he
was very important to its founding
absolutely clearly without hunch hunting
and gathering was the core of the
founding and then Wonder Woman came in
was like let me just take it over a girl
like her leather pants we're also so
important to the man sitting behind me
and that's where my biggest problems lie
I wondered if this is that okay I said
they were nitpicky they are but my
biggest problems are we went through
the entire Wonder Woman film and we
didn't get one up shot of her but and we
got four in this four up shots of her
like cheeks like you see her cheeks in
this film yeah you just I've just heard
a bunch of people clicking buy ticket
now yeah you're welcome
Wonder Woman film was directed by a
woman yeah this was directed by two men
it's obvious it's obvious because also
the eye i retweeted this on twitter and
it's a big thing they're warrior
leathers yeah yeah yeah are completely
different from the Wonder Woman film and
this film and there's just like a giant
mid-drift opening oh now that you
mention it I realize that that happened
but all I could think about watching
Justice League was look at their they're
incredible I mean they cast are just
like these muscled badass women and I
know they amazing but when I go into
battle yeah when I often do I don't like
to expose all of my vital organs and
they apparently do I'm just gonna play
I'm gonna play the devil yes please
because when Aquaman first showed up and
but he's just a he's a very striking
looking young man yeah he sure is he's
old he's a gorgeous guy like he had an
amazing sweater on and I was like that's
a great sweater my wife would love that
sweater and then he took the sweater
often and I was like my wife would love
those tattoos and all of that
musculature and then and then he starts
wading into the water and I'm like no
pants how cool man was the one out of
all the new characters we had cyborg we
had flash and we had Aquaman for the
newer ones
Aquaman was the one who didn't fit in
the most to me yeah he didn't have
anything to do he had one amazing
walking out of a bar drinking whiskey ah
to a key thump various actually he was
and but he just didn't fit the vibe
everyone had this weird DC feel to them
and it was very like surfer boy like no
oh I did the metal horns I meant to do
that
so these movies these like let's get a
bunch of heroes together kick some ass
movies yeah are they rely on everybody
bringing something to the table yeah
let's be honest Justice League
Batman has nothing on two gods no no or
even Barry Allen is has so outclasses
Batman
yeah I mean Batman has gadgets and they
kind of play to that a little bit and
Batman's great in the animated Justice
League yeah but in a live-action where
we're at as a movie-going audience what
we want to see out of our heroes it's
not quite like what we've seen out of
Wonder Woman to pair her with Batman
it's just kind of like oh I love cyborg
yeah I never read the comics that any
any comics that cyborg was in other than
Justice League
but I loved sorry poor kid Teen Titans I
don't know I didn't love cyborg in this
he's an integral part but like he all he
did he was the brooder this time Aquaman
2 it's like the heart and soul of this
movie is very Alan but other than that
Wonder Woman every time she's around you
feel better Batman this time you're like
okay this is a guy who like is involved
and having believes in things yeah not
all just murder which I loved by the way
that was my favorite part of BBS was how
much Batman murder P was murder
finally but I have always said this I've
said it on video I've said it in real
life I've said it to Ike my cat that
Superman not better than Superman is a
character I don't care to see in film
hmm I don't care he's too powerful like
I I would rather deal with someone who's
struggling but my hope is that's it for
the thing like this was the best
portrayal of Superman I've ever seen
outside of Tom Welling in Smallville I
like to go in current-day film this is
yeah
absolutely out of Henry's Henry's
portrayal of Superman this was the best
movie he's been his portrayal farm was
impeccable there was something wrong
with his upper lip other than that I
didn't care about the villain at all not
it not a villain was the weakest part of
this film watching everybody take on
newly resurrected Superman was the
highlight of this movie it was so well
constructed such a more crowd pleasing
way than what DC's been doing yeah yeah
and it did not look at all like his acts
neither movie because it all looked like
TV coverage hey Joss Whedon is an
amazing writer and he's a very capable
director he's my favorite like sitting
right there and he heard you Thank You
DC for not making it more than two hours
long thank you I had so much fun go see
you with Tamra you can't what's your
rating oh my gosh if under the lasso of
truth yeah yeah which I am you currently
are I was wearing a Wonder Woman shirt
and I spilled wine on it berries out of
an Allen nice eight I would give it 7.5
bearded Batman's I'm really impressed
I'm feeling really optimistic about the
DC Universe yeah and that makes me happy
because I want to see more I want to see
poison ivy I want to see oh my god
Catwoman really well portray I want to
see these really cool characters we're
reaching towards the end here where like
DC is like finally digging themselves
out of this hole I hope so put in thank
you for joining me thank you for
watching everyone thank you for being my
cat we will see you all or I will
someone will see you all next week
we'll see you soon bye
you